But the reason I bring that up is because there's this whole industry of people
that, uh, seem to not really contribute much to the publication process,
but they, they make themselves seem necessary for like,
if you want to be in the New York times bestseller list kind of thing,
but also just being like reputable. Yeah.
Which is I'm allergic to the whole concept, but it does.
Do you think it's possible to be on the New York times bestseller list and be a
reputable author and still be, self-published.
Not what you would want to do. Like people like Mark Sisson,
I think is his name. He wrote like the primal blueprint.
So like if I'm getting the names, correct. He's the first paleo guy, right?
So he's, he self-published it, it sold gangbusters. Um,
but that would be on their health chart, I believe. And, uh,
it's a little bit of a different situation.
You'd be reaching much more for the mainstream. Um,
you'd be giving up a lot if you go through a publisher, especially financially,
but yeah,
you are not going to have the credit because there publishing is a cartel,
the New York times as part of this cartel,
and if you don't publish within this cartel,
they will do what they can as any cartel has to,
by necessity of being cartel to pretend you don't exist. So they will,
uh, I was, I think the first one to have an hour on book TV for dear reader.
Cause that was a Kickstarter book. Um,
but this is something that people do read. It was a Kickstarter book. Yeah. Um,
this is something people would have to be aware of.
So you would be giving up a lot,
but you'd also be giving a lot to work with a publisher because you're losing
like a year and a half of your life because they're glacial and they don't care.
That's my problem. It's not the money. I mean,
the money is whatever percent they take. 10, 20, 30, 50.
They're taking a huge chunk. So if I sell a book through St. Martins,
it's a dollar. If I sell a book through Amazon, which is dear reader, that's $6.
So that's what, 87%. It's something crazy.
But for me, what bothers me, isn't the money that, that for me personally,
for me will bothers me as in competence.
Like whenever I go to the DMV or something like that.
Can I interrupt you? Yeah. Let's talk in confidence.
New ride comes out last year. Yes. I get on Rogan, get on Ruben.
All of them. And I said, I got in these shows,
is there money in the budget for travel?
And they say.
We don't have the budget.
Fine. By the way you got on those shows with no help from them.
Oh yeah. That's not even a question. Uh,
the reason they would want you to do a book is because they know you could get
the only reason people get book deals nowadays,
literally it's because they know that person can market their own book.
That's the only way. And I got a Ruben, I got a Rogan and they,
they go and have the money for the bunch for traveling, which is fair.
They can do Skype. They told me this in writing and I'm like, okay.
And.
They can financially cover Skype.
No, but it's like, Hey Joe. Yeah, we don't have the budget,
but you're going to do Skype.
So there is another friend of mine was
on a show on CNBC when the seem to lab.
And they said in the scene wants a copy of the book. And they're like, Oh yeah.
It's like four o'clock on Friday. So we're closed. So,
and he's like, he went there, picked it up and walked into the two blocks.
So there is, it's almost cartoonish. Yeah.
And it's not incompetence it's um, it's past that.
It's something almost,
you can't really believe that I've had two friends who have been literally
rendered suicidal, um, because this was such a huge opportunity for them.
And it was like watching their kid get beaten in front of them.
And I had to talk them off the ledge.
So it's people do not appreciate how bad here's another one.
The apathy of bureaucracy, something like that.
I did this book, concierge confidential. There's a typo in the first chapter.
Dan's with, I'm about to too. They didn't fix it for the paperback
carrot. It's just like, wow. Okay. Yeah. Great book. By the way. Got it.
Got NPR. Gave it one, the books of the year. So that was cool.
So why participate in this?
Otherwise New York times is going to pretend you don't exist. Uh,
getting booked on some booked on some shows might be more difficult.
Although I think that's collapsing in real time. Um,
you're not going to get reviewed necessarily places like PW, um,
or some others.
So the new book you're working on, you don't have a title yet or like pill,
the white pill. Are you self publishing that? Oh yeah,
for sure. And what's the thinking behind that?
Just because you already have a huge following and a big platform and uh.
It's six times the cash. If I finished the book in December,
I could have it out in February.
If I finished the book in December with the publisher,
it's going to be out in December at the earliest 20, 21.
Why am I giving up 10 months of my life?
Well, this is a big one. Do you have any leverage? Like do,
do authors have leveraged to say F you like, can you just say,
what do you mean? Just look meaning like, uh,
I want to release this book into me.
Oh no, no. I mean, you'll have a contract and then your agent can fight it,
but they don't have the Bureau.
They don't have the capacity to rush things through.
Yeah. I guess if the I've heard like big authors, I don't know, Sam Harris,
all those folks talk about like, they've accepted it actually they've accepted.
They're like, yeah. It takes a long time to, I'm.
Not accepting it, but.
Yeah, but you're kind of implying that a human being like me should, like,
I'm saying these are your options, right? So I just, I just hate it.
I hate the waiting because it's in competence. It's not the,
it's not necessarily the weight. If I knew it wasn't, you know,
if it was the kind of people that are all up at 2:00 AM at night,
on a Friday and they love what you're doing and they're helping create something
special. That's the sense I get with some of the Netflix folks, for example, uh,
that work with people. I just, I don't know anything about this world,
but you get like Netflix folks who, who help with shows.
You could tell that they're obsessed with those shows. Like, yeah,
you're not gonna get that publishing if you hand, like I handed the book in,
I think it was July. I didn't hear anything from my editor until December.